les fêtes des plantes du parti
communiste alors je voudrais pas que
notre entretien s'achève là et les pumas
il est 13h27 déjà monsieur oui oui oui
nous allons jusqu'à 13 heures 34 minutes
et moins encore à parler sport cgg a
parlé avec john c permettez je voudrais
dire que limité alors si rien dire avant
la scène démission je parle monsieur
mitterrand parce que moi j'avais pris
plein de notes en venant dans l'autre
version non je n'aurai pas le temps je
le sais déjà que j'ai pas le temps on
fait juste le temps de me mettre en
colère je commence maintenant
non c'est le système de la formation
française qui fait comme ça j'aurai le
temps une minute de m'énerver juste de
m'énerver de paraître pour un petit
merdeux un petit jeune de la pagaille
partout
je préfère m'en aller tout de suite si
j'avais su comment dire j'aurais dormi
beaucoup plus tard ayant souhaité votre
présence balavoine dans son studio pour
parler des problèmes de la jeunesse
pense que nous aurons eu tort nous
aurions eu le temps d'en parler c'était
vraiment pas de chance y aura les
indiens de suite et c'était pas de
chansons dont il était question parler
pendant 10 minutes au moins de la sphère
georges marchais dont tout le monde se
fout strictement je vous signale que la
jeunesse française se fout strictement
de ce que monsieur marché faisait
pendant la guerre sale vais complètement
égal ça intéresserait plus la jeunesse
de savoir ce qui se passe et comment le
parti communiste en caisse de l'argent
pour le dépenser après notamment la
mairie de bagnolet s'intéresserait mieux
de savoir comment gaston defferre dirige
sa mairie socialiste qui n'est pas un
modèle de société à marseille
s'intéresserait plus de savoir les
jeunes français comment monsieur raymond
barre qui est arrivé il ya cinq ans ou
quatre ans je ne sais plus combien de
temps a dit que les salaires ne seraient
pas diminué mais qui à augmenter les
cotisations de sécurité sociale c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant que tout ce
que vous racontez georges marchais on
s'en fout de georges marchais il faut le
savoir de ce qui faisait pendant la
guerre ça nous est complètement égal le
problème de drogue de la façon dont on
le traite les ministres français on s'en
fout il n'y a jamais un jeune ministre
delà de la jeunesse en france il y en a
jamais c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur soissons enfin vous
allez pas me dire que c'était un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent billets com - les jeunes que
comme monsieur soissons il faut quand
même pas rêver
tout ça ce sont des métiers j'ai encore
pris plein de notes au fur et à mesure
que vous parlez ce que voudrait savoir
ce qui nous intéressait le savoir acquis
les travailleurs immigrés paye les
loyers qui paye
on a vu tout à l'heure des gens qui
disaient on paye 700 francs par mois je
serai savoir qu'ils enquêtent
de l'argent pour louer des poubelles
pareil c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on me
dise c'est pas de savoir comment on peut
faire pour changer je voudrais qu'ils
osent tout les mois devenant des 700
francs à des travailleurs immigrés pour
vivre dans des poubelles dans des taudis
ça c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on
m'explique pas ce que moi je ne le sais
pas c'est pas la force et la formation
qui me dit je voudrais savoir pourquoi
monsieur boulin était suicidé ou s'est
suicidé ou on ne le saura jamais
pourquoi monsieur fontana a été
assassiné pourquoi la sphère de broglie
n'a jamais été éclairés pourquoi ne juge
renaud on sait pas ni pourquoi ni
comment il a été assassiné
j'en ai d'autres la seule chose que je
peux vous dire monsieur mitterrand j'en
profite de vous avoir parce que je suis
fier d'être là je peux vous le dire on
sent la personne peut-être pas ne vous
pouvez pas imaginer ce que c'est pour un
jeune d'avoir la possibilité de parler
une minute c'est pour ça que j'avais
peur de ne pas pouvoir parler parce que
ça n'arrive jamais faut bien se mettre
en tête
ça n'arrête jamais regardé l'émission
qui a eu hier soir sur antenne 2 les
dossiers l'écran enfin vous n'allez pas
me dire que les mômes qui étaient
concernés par la contrainte d'abandonner
c'est vraiment la chance elle vient je
sais on est obligé côté vous exagérez
l'information je suis obligé résultat je
la résume à ma manière que j'essaie de
lire rapidement mes notes ce que je vous
donnais en tout cas c'est généralement
c'est un avertissement
j'ai peut-être du culot de faire ça je
suis obligé de le faire comme ça parce
que je dois faire vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française et moi je pense qu
est la règle générale en résumant un peu
bien raison ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le désespoir et mobilisateur
et que lorsqu'il devient mobilisateur il
est dangereux et que ça entraîne le
terrorisme la bande à baader et des
choses comme ça et ça il faut que les
grandes personnes qui dirigent le monde
soit prévenu que les jeunes vont finir
par virer du mauvais côté parce qu'ils
n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir assez
parlé monsieur mitterrand voulait des
lieux dialoguer avec un jeune vous
l'avez écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
ce qui ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est
que cette façon de penser de réagi et
aussi de s'exprimer parce qu'en face
daniel balavoine s'exprime par les cris
par la musique
et droit de cité puisse être entendue et
donc puisse être comprise le dire sa
manière il est responsable de ces
paroles c c'est un citoyen comme un
autre mais typique et quand je dis
typique c'est parce qu'ils représentent
à mon sens des centaines de milliers de
jeunes conditions de vie ou dans quelle
banlieue
quel logement quels loisirs entrant dans
une société bétonnées qui se ferment
partout de vente avec le chômage pour
perspective pense que quelqu'un qui sait
dire et chanter c'est à dire exprimer
sous la forme de l'art un drame vécu de
cette force devait être entendue lors
d'une émission de ce genre là pourquoi
condamner de la boyne parle
effectivement ils rejettent bon
l'information c'est dans l'autre relève
mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils rejettent
tous les hommes politiques qu'ils soient
de droite ou du même village et il a le
droit
et pourquoi pas moi il a le droit moi je
suis pour que tout soit dit et pour que
tout homme politique puisse être remise
en question ça m'arrive tous les jours
et si cela devait arriver avec daniel
balavoine bien j'écouterai quand même ce
qu'il a à me dire
alors voilà pourquoi cela ne doit pas
amener un deuxième incident de séance
autour de cette émission mais comme il
était 13h33 gouédic se définira 3g
dernier le gazon n'a pas encore dans les
lycées les passionnés sur le football
c'est ça que je veux vous dire daniel
brême que l'on ne peut pas résumer la
politique française avec à des conflits
d'ailleurs provoquer artificiellement
par le parti communiste entre georges
marchais moi avoue rené andré je suis
sûr que telle était votre intention
au nom donc je ne voulais plus femmes et
seulement nuit si nous nous adressons à
des millions de gens qui ont besoin de
savoir qu'on n'ait pas pu parler encore
du 1,9 pour cent d'augmentation des prix
mois janvier d un million cinq cent
mille chômeurs aujourd'hui dès 9
milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur sur les deux premiers mois de
l'année soit presque autant que toute
l'année dernière qu'on n'ait pas pu
parler de la situation des épargnants
qui vont peut-être voir augmenter de 6
et demi pour cent à 7 % la rémunération
de leur épargne
tandis que la spéculation conduit par
exemple et les grandes sociétés qui
peuvent emprunter ce monsieur
les grandes sociétés peuvent emprunter à
20% aux etats-unis d'amérique et la
dévaluation de fait du franc j'étais la
dernière réussite de monsieur bah
dévaluation de fait en face d'un dollar
à 440 et d'un marquage de francs 40 ans
alors je veux dire kenya nous allons
être lumière quand même il ya quand même
deux politiques il faut faire le choix
vers celle que je dénonce et il ya
celles qui est contenue dans le projet
socialiste tient pas d'autres voilà
pourquoi je leur ai dit même si on ne
m'en a pas laissé beaucoup de la bible